bonjour et bienvenue championnat de
france 2016 à gien après la septième
ronde reçoit de nouveaux
l'extraordinaire la sensation d'agen
2016 c'est jean françois joly bonjour
jean françois bonjour alors c'est
vraiment la sensation parce
qu'effectivement on le disait un peu
avant l'émission mais ils sont tous
grands maîtres et toi tu es bon c'est
déjà très tout à fait exceptionnelle tu
es déjà maître international serait déjà
forcé ouais mais c'est quand même pas
mal et donc mais là tu réussi un tournoi
super mais encore aujourd'hui alors hier
en avait reçu de laurent frayssinet qui
avait réussi à marquer des points contre
toi mais aujourd'hui tu t'es pas
démoralisés obama s'est aussi j'étais
content le volley-club le rang comme
tape sur jusqu'au temps de réguler et
déjà c'était super mais aujourd'hui on
aurait pu dire bon
il a dilapidé faîtière mais non non tu
as joué avec vraiment enthousiaste ça se
voyait dans les coups on parce que tu as
joué une partie très agressive
on va voir ça et puis bon face à un
client quand même sébastien feller grand
maître a presque deux mille six cents
lots donc bon c'est quand même pas voilà
c'est un petit joueur
donc c'est sûr que c'était pas évident
et tu te retrouves ce soir de nouveau en
tête du national
ado rondes de la fin tu es à égalité
avec yannick gozzoli et mathieu cornette
qui là aussi
fonçons le lead alors derrière juste
derrière en poursuite
on a laurent frayssinet qui est toujours
placé mais qui n'a fait que nul face à
christian bauer est lui aussi toujours
placé qui sans voir le champion en titre
donc tout est encore possible sur deux
rondes mais au moins on peut dire
maintenant tu te fais partie des favoris
pour le titre
2016 c'est quand même génial et alors et
oui c'est fou et alors et je vais te
dire un truc bon juste d'un point de vue
historique c'est amusant parce qu'on a
regardé ça pendant le direct avec
manuela pis là est ce que tu sais la
dernière fois qu'un maître international
a gagné le national 4 christian 96
exactement bravo exactement là en fait
même les trois années consécutives je
crois qu'il ya eu eric prier avant et
âme un manuel à pisser l'avant et je
sens après c'était ça doit être versée
en 97 après ça doit être
d'hoffmann tous exactement donc
apprécier tiko des grands maîtres
surtout il ya plus de maîtres qui ont
remporté le national depuis bauer en
1996 il a été quand m l'année d'après il
est donc ce qui fait qu effectivement
réussira un bon score même sans gagner
outils d'ailleurs au national ça donne
une au moins une norme de grands maîtres
du jeu est donc temps à d'autres normes
ça serait la première met donc pourquoi
pas derrière bon on n'en est pas là tu
vas jouer les parties tu m'as dit les
unes après les autres à la raison comme
les footballeurs au match après match
après match
donc si vous voulez on va voir cette
super party entre donc toi et sébastien
feller donc c'est parti avec eux 4 4
notre live agency sicilienne qu'avec
trois des six jusque là tu t'attendais à
sa part problème des 4 puis on prend
même à les prendre et la grille m6
surprise là tout est normal qu a laissé
trois à six donc la falaise nov
ouais pas surprise donc lui qui joue et
ça je vais vous avez deux choix
d'habitude de cette position je joue
tout le temps faut 2 wii est donc là
donc je suis préparée par le maître
international temps guimiliau jeu devant
un petit coucou au passage et les filles
méritoire qui m'ont aidée par il n'est
pas sur place mais
ne t'en vois qu'elle aime envoyer le
coup qu enfin quelques analyses avec le
kuga et b3 ça me plaisait bien leur
mental et préparer sa gratuité quand
même attendu à ce que s'il va signifier
leur joue cette partie des possibilités
ouais ouais
et donc qu'ils avaient préparé cette
secoue alors figure toi qu'on a eu
maxime d'achille j'ai vu sept passages
agen et donc il a commenté ta partie et
il avait dit il c'est vrai que le couple
est arrivé 3 elle pas et pas forcément
le plus doit être assez rare en jeu
voilà c'est exactement
donc finalement tu es toi qui l'a
surpris en promis sans doute je passais
ma gueule à la joie comme quand même
assez vite donc en fait c'est tombé
peut-être un peu long mais c'est pas
grave ça me plaisait bien parce que
voilà le plan était clair fallait
pousser les pions à la loi donc pas
tranquille quoi je n'étais pas le plus
mal à l'aise voilà tu étais pas à l'aise
en pointe était en terrain inconnu si ce
que tu cherchais à faire donc au cices
hélas alors labeaume c'est parti voilà
j'ai 4 du coup l'intérêt de cavaliers b3
c'est que peut jouer g400 que le pinot
noir avant son no 5 qui attaquerait le
cavalier en d4 et il y aurait une double
attaque qui a fait ça l'idée double cab
et trois en fait mais alors il aurait pu
jouer autre chose que si si si le câble
et sans escale et 17 ans wade aussi ce
même dessin tout de suite je sais pas
mort et b5 sont peut-être avaient
préparé des choses
de toute façon mais aussi ce bon
évidemment l'attaquait les alliés
naturels c'est ça ressemble à une
attaque qui restent sont dit oui une
attaque yougoslave aussi parfois
dangereux dans ce genre là quoique en
tout cas on balance se plonger casse la
gueule g4 on nous la colonne fans ont
soumis ouvre la colonne presque et puis
on veut jouer g5 déstabiliser ce
cavalier envoyés au pian et puis c'est
de casser un futur rock ou même la
structure des pions
si le roi peut être exactement florent
que voilà c'est l'idée générale donc ici
b5 donc envoyé en bessin s'est tout de
suite pose une petite question qu'est ce
qu'on fait sur des quatre puisque le
client à 4 et est attaqué comme un fou
j'ai deux petites menaces sur la tour on
a huit donc il doit faire flamber 7 pour
couvrir way en menace que les hommes il
ya eu cinq attaques lecavalier si
j'avais 10 ans anton prince est très bon
donc voilà fou bessette et la bôme gsm
maintenant voilà importance que je dois
chacel cavaliers pour un peu protégé mon
pions ans le 4 way alors il aurait
peut-être pu jouer ici b4 c'est possible
c'est aimer c'est compliqué du coup
parce que alors je crois que massimo
sheeran nous a dit mais sur des tons
plus qu'à l'idée c'est ça c'est ce que
le cavaliere est attaqué dans tous les
cas si on prend ici on prend un essai et
si on prend du curieux ont répondu
qu'ils ont et puis on peut et sait
exactement d'accord donc bon forcément
si on a maxime ça va plus ça sonne assez
facile donc cavalier en dix-sept normal
ou alors il a maintenant fait 3 tu finis
son développement faut quand même se
retrouver place un petit peu s'en faut
pas oublier de sortir les pièces aux
échecs c'est important est sans doute tu
vas faire le grand roque évidemment
quand on à pousser les pions comme ça on
en vit des banques
on n'a pas envie de se mettre du côté on
a affaibli ses pions que ça peut arriver
une fois donc la cave ayew 5 voilà il
veut qu'elle sait qu'à tout le cas et
c'est très bien placé un peu gênant ce
qui va attaquer le fouet le pion mais 2
me fous et en mai 2 et puis du coup on
se demande après on peut se demander si
finalement sortir le fou la silly boy
peut-être c'était pas très loin
je sais que dans ce que j'avais su
rester h 4 qui avait été joué mais ça me
plaisait pas ce plaisir donc là en fait
tu te pose pas de questions tu dis c'est
pas grave dames deux logiques si logique
a finalement parce que calais c4 grand
roque et voilà c'est juste pas grave on
apprécie le prendre le four du coup il
aura perdu pas mal de temps de
développement
bon ben ça ça tu dis c'est pas du tout
sépare a bien sûr j'ai par la paire de
fou mais te ra jouer un deux trois
quatre cinq contre un et deux coups donc
j'ai gagné du temps en fait le problème
que je peux avoir
je m'en suis pas vraiment rendu compte
tout de suite tout de suite c'est que
quand il fallait il peut pas jouer tout
de suite mais le coût des saints mais 4
way qui attaquent le quai en c3 va avec
toujours me poser un petit peu de
problèmes parce que kyle et c3 n'a pas
la case de retrait rôle de madame et
s'appelle ma beauté parce que si le
mérou à 4 il aura presque pas de case et
si je le mets en berne
pas terrible non plus c'est très lent ça
va être un thème qui va réveiller enfin
qui va être assez l'attend dans la
partie à dire coin tout à fait donc la
limite donc ça t'arrange qui prennent un
le four et le château dans la case
horaire pour le cavalier quoi t il
développer ce qui paraît logique aussi
sur l'autre cavalier lui aussi il faut
qu'ils se développent souvent à la nage
dorff le fou là ils bougent pas quoi qu
il sent que très tardivement il faut que
les noirs ont poussé des cinq quand il
arrive à le faire donc la f4 voilà je
prends les spurs c'est peut-être ça
m'aidera à faire f 5 un jour au real à
noter qu'on a quand même vis-à-vis d'un
droit là aussi donc si les noirs se
décide pas alors si je vous faut c'est
être l' attaque prend du poids parce que
j'y perds un peu de temps personne et
s'ils ne jouent pas et bien vis-à-vis
d'un droit aux épices excuses aussi
s'attarder
m et si le signe zip afsset et tirana il
va m'attaque à la lhdaa mais lors le
fouet la tour en moins pour attaquer
voilà douze ans le souhait suite et la
fin au cloud de suite parfois il peut
vite revenir dans la partie
il est venu en a trois mais trop tard
donc ici fawcett
donc il a un petit pression sur le pion
jessold je pense cash cadre de toute
façon pour le protéger c'est normal
c'est bien ça te permet d'envisager f5
sans perdre le clan gestion et puis il
ya une autre un autre intérêt h4 sexy
fait eu 5 pour enlever le pion aux 9,4
maintenant voilà il peut pas faire ça
est-ce que j'aurai afssa qui aimait piot
serait trop fort bien évidemment un g5
qui est bien protégé alors que
s'arrachent 4 on en
c'est pour cela c'était quand même
importante a fait donc la up
tours s'est vite normale normale mais en
revenant de finances il n'ya pas perdre
du temps la recette
il réfléchit pas mal de temps en fait
alors là il y avait une variante j'ai
fait fou des quatre essais la variante
cas c'est assez sympa on réattaque le
clergé cette attaque g7 et un coup il
est à vous qui posez une grosse question
c'est le coup b4 ab4 encore quand même
c'est celui-là qui te gêne le plus en
fait moi ça ce que j'avais je pense j'ai
trouvé quelque chose de bien
en fait au départ j'ai regardé fou prend
ghsr cela aurait maintenant voilà donc
j'attaque la tour tour j'ai huit jours
s'il prend ici tu prends la tour bien
sûr donc ce we se voit donc ici tour
j'ai vite food et 4 qu'il revient
d'éclat il prend le cavalier a déjà deux
fils devant moi j'étais je me demandais
ce que cette position est intéressante
parce que j'ai deux pieux bon la tour
gémit-elle un peu en vue oui parce qu'il
nomme un cadre historique il a de plus
jamais le rock voilà alors il va
toujours avoir des problèmes pour le
placebo enfin déjà ça c'est très
compliqué que d'autres que c'est plutôt
sympa à jouer même si ça c'est peut-être
pas très correct et j'ai trouvé une note
dario je pense qu'il me voir ovni une
autre qui prend fin qui n'excède là je
pense un après je sais pas trop
l'évacuation
oui voilà food et 4,6 jouber quatre
mécanos fait je vais jouer que la vallée
des saints oui il ya toujours une idée
là qu'à valider cinq effectivement donc
le monde alors il doit je pense qu'ils
doivent de prendre tout ce qu'il veut et
dehors du menace de prendre le fou de
cases noircies c'est une catastrophe je
pense d'elle qui peut relier aussi donc
je sais pas mais oui mais ici roche
prend le fou et je pense que je sois là
où et quand même mieux de qui prend donc
il prend le canal aux époux projet cette
même et mon l'empêcher de rock'n un faux
projet s'est très vite le rock tour
gelid je reviens au décade donc lui en
fait j'ai gagné un prix au nord par
rapport aux autres variantes
oui mais j'ai à présent celle là est
bien mais parce que là il est la colonie
il a souvent forcément le monde et oui
tout est ouvert la série même s'il prend
tu reprends dirait si ouvert le prochain
coup ses prises ici tu va doubler et
tripler et à la fin je savais pas trop
comment juger cette position mais
j'avais l'impression que c'était des
grosses compensation qui mate
j'étais pas aussi bien aussi sur babolat
me plaisait bien c'est bon ça vient ça a
l'air d'être matin moi je dis que c'est
matt donc du coup il a joué avec nos 5
voilà pour m'empêcher diplôme et que
donc j'ai pris je pense que la normale
je t'avoue que je m'attendais plutôt ce
qui traîne un câble dans le doubs
cavalier est ce qu'on s'est dit c'est
qu'une fois que tu as pris là à la casse
des 5es faible maintenant et donc oui
c'est qu'on a je suis très content
d'avoir provoqué le sac parce que
maintenant je n'ai plus le problème des
cinq b4 vu que mon cavalier c3
maintenant à la casse des cinq tailles
et les cas voilà exactement ce problème
là il est résolu que il ya toujours une
case de sortie d'autant que des cinq
protégé par le club bien sûr halimi même
si à l'épaule survenue plongé de
savourer toutes les lignes mais en plus
il ya le sujet dès qu'ils voient leur
donc c'est très bon et là effectivement
bon goût fou et f2 puisque tu gardes la
dame sur la colonne du roi là je me
laisse pas changer maintenant le ce que
basso cavaliers restait qu'à très fort
mais il n'a pas grand chose mais pas
tout de suite entre la graphie toi rien
c'est à dire que la préfère garder mon
roi fou pour l'instant ouais faut garder
mais surtout garder ce foutoir sont plus
à l'est le oui tu allais pas le mettre
en 3 il faisait rien 3 ici tu peux
peut-être plus tard le matin je me sens
jamais si jamais voire même en e1 pour
ça ce n'est pas sifflé le mans alors
d'annoncer cette menace as well as s'il
est normal qu'à et prend b2 si je fais
rien america allait prendre b2 apprend
et d'un prince et 3 j'ai peut-être même
dans un autre sens faut regarder qu'elle
prend b2 or prend b2 alors ils sont là
trois imaginons que les blancs jouent un
coût et en même temps qu'est ce que je
peux jouer deux rôles
admettons un booster de voir qu'il ne
pourra pas terrible
vous serez prend b2 est allé prendre les
deux bons parce que peut-être je peux
prendre lui des bêtises
bien sûr vous l'apprendre je suis pas
pour que je compliquer la tenue d'un
procès trois celui d'un enfant de fou
être gelée je veux être fou à tora et
seimat
ouais donc c'est pas bon voilà donc
attention dames c'est cette c'est l'idée
est aussi de calais b 4 de calais c4
pardon on attaque b2 avec voyez une
attaque une attaque de type colonne
c'est ici avec le case noire qui
deviennent totalement faible côté côté
blanc donc il faut aller très vite
prouver quelque chose profiter au club
d'avoir au développement donc la fois en
trois ans soit 3 alors l'affouage 3 donc
tu crimes contre la nation total quatre
cavaliers donc les et plus ou moins but
de faire tour des huit je crois alors on
regarde quand même parce que qu'est ce
qui se passe sur cavaliers prend des
deux camps mais malgré tout ça marche
pas khoualed moi je mange ce que tu
manges ici échec il obligé de jouer le
roi ait fui ces jugements ou je mangerai
tour tu manges la tour donc du coup
d'oeil et humain je mangeais encore le
fou s'il prend le travail et tu prends
le fou et il n'a pas demain à saint gall
quoique il faut à trois quand même
derrière donc la guiche près d'un pont
avec dame français trouvent way down
princes et rois et bien essayé oui pas
sinon c'est foutu
en fin de compte que essayant de voir
dame princes et rois
je t'avoue que je peux déjà vous dire
que calais des 3c mollasson moi je fais
foot pro b c'est toujours le fun faut
prendre 17 a pas peur de fouras 3g ce
qu'il peut y avoir matos il ya cette
vallée vite là donc là faut faire gaffe
quand même mais peut-être simplement tu
laisses le matos c'est à dire
suffisamment la lance tu peux jouer
d'alger près de manger une tour oui mais
voilà si j'aime toujours je vais jouer
plutôt un coup je peux je vais peut-être
avoir un truc comme ça vous fout hein
pour chasser encore mise 9 mai salle
armand oui parce que sur cavaliers
detroit tu t'en fous il ya tournant et
il n'y a pas d'échec j'ai regardé si je
me prenais un événement cavaliers
detroit échec il faut à 3 mai
donc les traits d'un contrôle de la casa
par exemple s'il fait cavalier de
détroit je peux prendre de la tour et il
n'y a pas de matière sur foix iii roi
des fautes ou reprend il n'y a pas de
match puisque sur fou à 3 au lieu
d'aller en b1 messieurs je vais en d1 et
après je pourrai jouer l'un des deux va
s'en sortir on s'en sort et on a trop de
matos d' avance donc ça marche pas donc
fois je crois est une vraie contre
attaque
pouf pouf j'élimine j'élimine du matos
et donc autour des 8 est quasiment forcé
tour des 8es ils pouvaient pas ok non
plus oui parce qu'ils perdaient une
pièce donc joli coup la 1 fois je crois
ce qu'on replace le fou il était un peu
bloquée maintenant il a plus drôle
finalement un petit pécule active un
petit peu beaucoup
il est vachement lait je m'en débarrasse
là donc les tuteurs débarrasse
finalement oui mais ce que j'aime c'est
à dire que ses biens dont l'un très bien
je pensais bien parce que si ce qu'avait
dit bouge le foot nathan de vie devrait
donc tu te dis c'est plutôt la jarne
enchaînements de coups forcez pas être
désagréable c'est bon on sait très bien
jouer fou prend tout reprend maintenant
tout reprendre 17 carrément télé min ou
dans prend pour éviter de rocky leroy et
lacs et ses 5 et la superbe cavalli c5
on sent ce cavalier qui est finalement
un peu passif il va s'échanger contre un
défaut donc on élimine à perdre fout pas
mal
donc là il a un choix désagréable se
faire [ __ ] incessants avec les dents
skype ou rapport aucune île pendant
qu'est ce que je fous empêchera le rock
quasiment advitam eternam
ici ce qui va lui poser des gros soucis
soit les modestes manger sont floues 17
mai dans ce cas je vais avoir le
contrôle absolu de la case des 5 et ça
va être
du bonheur désagréable donc déjà la
superbe avec des moyens voyez assez
assez finalement simple c'est assez
logique c'est stratégique
c'est une bonne compréhension du jeu
d'échecs finalement on n'est pas maître
par hasard et regardez regardez sa dame
c7
donc on donne pas ce fou parce que fou
prend et le roi ne pourra jamais évoqué
ce qui fait que cette tour va pas jouer
pendant un long moment
la tour blanche elle va venir en jeu il
va avoir des gros soucis pour les noirs
donc on préfère donner l'autre fou mais
après qu'elle allait prendre mais cette
dame 30-17 et bien le coup suivant
regarder on aurait même pu choquer mais
je vais tourner un tel tour des hommes
c'est pas top
de toute façon là j'ai un bon avantage
stable avec nos cavaliers en dessin
alors après oui j'étais vraiment content
si tu parce que si tu veux gagner des
scènes qu'elle soit à tour finalement il
bien bien
en fait j'ai joué le tour d'un la base
je pensais que la kilbi la roque et un
vent de la rocqué et au départ mon idée
de base c'était de faire déloger 4 tu
voulais faire d'alger quatre monnaies ce
tour 17
manas en fait la joie personnelle de
menaces pas tant que ça parce qu'ils
peuvent eux-aussi 8 et je peux pas
prendre le fou skoda mais pas des fins
vous allez bien le voir j'avais pas vu
au département joël adam aussi vite tout
de suite montré tout de suite j'espérais
qu'il fasse tour des huit pour moi ce
qui me paraissait plus écologique et là
maintenant qu'à valider cinq
et maintenant quel rider c'est plein de
petites menaces sur ces pièces s'y fait
on y suit ya qualifié là et je menace
six jours et aux glaces poussées pour
dévier le fou de la protection de la
tour par exemple à rossi à will genia
sont pas mal d'idées de cette position
de désagréments mémoire n'était pas du
tout forcé c'est peut-être pas très
malin c'était pas trop grave peut-être
apprécié
comme ça m'avantage ce thème c'est pas
très grave mais c'est assez stable il ya
passé assez statique en fait ici
commence à être très mal autant donc
donc allée des cinq co n'ont pu donc
joué le coup d'avant mais qui est bien
ici le prix et donc il est super ce
cavalier sert qu'en plus on peut pas
venir le contesté par le betis puisque
ce fief de m voilà un petit peu c'est
important ça d'ailleurs plus tard dans
la partie
ça va être cruciale la quasi jamais vu
ça va être important alors donc fou des
six ça c'est curieux mais bon il veut
pas je crois que c'est bien c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal mais bon alors c'est
un peu bizarre parce qu'il se met quand
même le fou sur la taille de la tour ce
qui fait que si on arrive à chasser ce
qu'a menée par une b3 lequel il bouge
ses on a peur de l'eau mais en fait on
se dit que après réflexion mais sur b3
il peut toujours faire flouer chèque
voilà laura bush et à brive où jamais la
belle ce qui fait que le fou n'est pas
devin la tournée ce cas là donc c'est
peut-être pour te provoque et d'ailleurs
qui fait ça peut-être s'être est une
provoc il est c'est-à-dire vas-y jouer 3
et puis moi je vais vous échec je vais
pas jouer de cavani bien sûr parce que
il ya une menace depuis en fait ils te
provoque il décède poussé à faire une
menace en un coup mettez un peu plus
subtil puisque tu joues un très joli
coup je pensais plus jolis coups de la
partie ça avec est bien avec fois je
crois qui finalement est un coup de
simplification très fort ch 5
la chine passe un très joli coup puisque
la menace positionnelle c'est une masse
positionne à 6 h déjeuner page il a tout
fait pour l'éviter
ouais je crois qu'à un moment j'aurais
pu jouer j'ai trop un clergé verser je
pense orly dh si c'est qu'on élimine le
logo y fait d'ailleurs le fait que le
fou sont bien dessinées ne pouvait pas
parce qu'il est fou prend qu'échec en
élimine le pion 17 ce qui rend les cases
m6 et h6 faible et alors ou alors je
vous g6 il a quand même la caspienne ici
et le cavalier va se régaler il va se
régaler puis le fou aussi il va se
régaler en fait tout le monde se régale
et là c'est le beau gosse pour l'instant
tout se passe bien donc c'est le dame
s'est vite du coup donc là il a déjà
plus beaucoup de temps donc il doit
jouer qu'un bon coup parce qu'il y avait
un virage 3 en fait owono 6% c'est que
c'était pour venir au no 6 pour tenir un
peu les 15 h aura sans doute fort je
pense parce que c'est possible il veut
contrôler à 15 h 1 et en cas d' âge si
si il contrôle aussi à tous celles en
béton et du coup ton cou et suivants et
très fort parce que dame et froid voilà
tu prends les cases on met les pieds je
commence à me lasser très sérieusement
h6 maintenant parce que s'il fait j'ai 6
g de 9,6 les maisons de la mairie ce
matin le suivi du mathan g7 dans le
problème donc la dame des huit c'est
très bien il attaque l'option des 5
alors grands noms rouge
en fait je pensais qu'ils allaient jouer
des mots 6 et j'avais prévu il y avait
une variante ouais d'accord donc sur
2003 imaginent-ils 06 donc je pensais
jouer h 6 h is quand même - la g6 pour
garder le jeu fifa ne pas ouvrir les
colonnes en ml 6 pour forcer les changes
de dames pour moi d'abord 6 pour les
battues vous adorez vous c'est une
question est mal posée à la balançoire 6
voilà malgré des changes est prise avec
échec
vous avez kechiche 8 h 8 et la d3
détroit
l'adac lecavalier s'est déliée ses
pièces il a le foot emprise donc on n'a
pas le choix il faut faire d'abord j'ai
trois robes et ont donc le cavalier là
que la case des six ce qu'on la sent que
cette équipe peut venir en un seul jeu
c'est peut-être mais c'était de même
mais bon bref je pensais que sur canal
et des six là j'avais fou g3 et le pion
aux 5 est perdue aux as chris est très
important ce puits ont évidemment c'est
presque maths alors qu'ils vont
peut-être que peut-être quand vous venez
ça qui pourrait venir défendre ses six
arrivées ensemble jeu c'était possible
ça va trop loin là c'est un peu plus
compliqué bon je garde avant je garde
l'avantagé que je tente et celui là il a
plus drôle sans voix et complètement
coincé
peuple en finale ça va être en béton sur
c'est embêtant mais tu vas jouer aussi
tour 17
et qu'est ce qui fait peut plus bouger
j'ai l'impression que je peux même
peut-être joué cavalier 17 et qui avait
mangé un clown cirque loué par la tour
mais tours 17
et après tu vous par exemple ces trois
races et 2 tu améliores tes pieds ce qui
pourrait faire un peu attention jours
tuvalu ramasser les pions a et b je
crois que tour des cinq aussi c'est bien
donc ça a l'air déjà foutu c'est fou
hein donc voilà les la jada long des
huit donc du coup beaucoup
ouais et à plus j'essayais d'un petit
oeil aussi sur la case à 5
ça peut monter peut-être une contre
attaque assez rapide faut que je me mets
aussi faut se méfier le tout à fait faux
se vivre en tant que la dame et la tonne
défense latérale aussi donc oui c'est
pas trop trop inquiet alors là je vais
quad alger qu'à trouver un bon coup je
pense alors l'appareil lorsque c'était
commençait déjà à manquer de talent
qu'est ce qu'ils jouent à damas six
coupes j'avais regardé
admettons qu aux devoirs si c'est
correct ou pas alors demain seniors
plage plage de cavalière six échecs
bien sûr ces chèques donc là il peut pas
prendre parce que s'il prend nous avons
hâte leurs forces
voilà et celle de la dame justice
d'alger cette terminé en serre la main
et si donc il est obligé de prendre un
peu jour je suis tout de suite je suis
là j'avais 2005 et je crois que c'est
moi qui vais mater en premier si je dis
pas de bêtises
j'espère ce que c'est important comme
bolt oui donc la menace m'attend h7 donc
s'y prend le cavalier il va se faire
mater par des six ouvrages et 8 h à 10
et c'est fini à matt en n'y a pas
d'échec il a pas d'échec on n'a pas le
temps pour ça j'ai toujours un temps de
et la patron ch j-6 donc je comprends g6
on l'a vu c'est à antibes rassemble les
jeux projet 6 en fait je me laisse j'ai
toujours je vous laisse j'ai cet échec
est de 3,7 alors une mi temps qui passe
d'un voleur à deux voies la dame prend à
dauger cet échec et c'est moi qui arrive
au premier cours apprend et la dame
times est mat
moi ça va c'est assez facile à calculer
l'un comme donc là on est commerçant un
g6 et 6h au projet si ce donc là il peut
pas prendre du plomb h mais mr mat et
par la tour par la toux ou d'élevage 3
est vendue plus bref voilà et la dame 17
9 ans il prendrait la fallait le voir
arriver un modèle 7 à 16 ans aux jo et
tactique je vous assure dame ses sept
tours prend 2,6 alors il n'y a pas le
choix la ici donc de la sodam ses sept
tours prend des 6es oui parce que j'ai
pas joli oui mais tu l'aurais vu et oui
tout reprend à oui très fort parce que
donc évidemment sida me prendre dans
maintenant j'ai gagné un nouveau passage
voilà si d'autres ont tout essayé
d'apprendre tour je suis management et
sicav allait prendre tour ben je perds
la dame c'est parce que j'ai au lit des
six superbes
voilà donc comment ils payent potage aux
dames à 5 il est obligé de rester en
défense
ou alors il en fait elle qui donne la
qualité c'est un peu fou tu vois
d'accord donc la voilà donc damascène
marche pas donc il fait dame service 6,8
propose échange de dames
mais non tu refuses c'est wasquehal
attaque ici on aime et puis il a plus
beaucoup de temps donc le même sens les
dames j'ai bien davantage avec le cas
dans des salons et mais faut garder la
pression je pense garder la pression
mais sur tout à fait surtout qu' il n'y
a pas de raison ne pas jouer l'attaquant
premier c'est toi toi t'as pas bougé ses
pions à la limite légale à la cie fait
si ferrero jeunesse hh 6 vous pareil est
sûre j'ai six cavaliers six échecs et
j'élimine le fou pour faire des preuves
sans que ça doute
ah oui oui superbe superbe imaginons que
les noirs les autres centrales et
essayons de voir ça donc tu aurais joué
h6 pour affaiblir encore une fois les
cases noires donc sans doute g6 va
permettre parce que si on prend ici non
seulement à phoebe la classe mais en
plus on a ouvert le dow jones qui
peuvent acceptable alors donc
aujourd'hui 6 pour fermer et la tour est
joué sans doute kabylie et 6 échecs roi
fuite et tu reprends des superbes sasebo
peu près je sais pas si c'est ça la
force à la fois parce que voulez vous
visuellement c'est sympa mais vincent
monnet ainsi oui mais là ce matin menace
cavaliers huit échecs qui qui quasiment
on peut aussi mettre food et quatre pour
aider si je mets donc je cassais 4
encore il peut attaquer la dame et je
fais de nous des cats je reste je garde
mes menaces salaire quand même assez
pénible il peut jouer autour des huit
noms qu'elle décède sur tour des mythes
il a maintenant qu'à valider cet échec
est sûre g8 ya mat sur f système
problème 6 donc c'est matt donc donc
c'est foutu aussi c'est la maladie sans
qu'elles aient 17 ou quelle limite on
peut donc ça a l'air foutu qu'est ce qui
peut faire d'autre bref c'est compliqué
peut-être dame d'amendé vite parce qu'il
est issu et d'énigmes c'est pareil tu
vas faire caler 17 tu prends la tour oui
mais oui madame et protège tu prend
l'intonation f6 tu prends la tour
puisque la dame est protégé
voilà et si prendre la dame de même
obligé de reprendre ici tu peut chasser
le cavalier éventuellement tu peux tu
peux tout faire en fait ça a l'air ça a
l'air complètement raide donc ici dame
g3 du garde les dames et donc d'un v6 il
vient protéger la vis à vis de la case
logic peut-être c'est peut-être là que
j'allais rater oui c'est l'attelage 6 au
8 août a fait la cie salaires jouable
donc j'aurais dû le faire
c'est le moment je lâche 6 ha oui on
s'était dit ouais je crois que andrei
dernier voilà voilà justement je
commence à l'échec est là simplement
joue par o'shea de ses maths mais
d'alger 6 voilà et là ceci dit c'est
peut-être bien quand même
ouais je pense que c'est très bien 1
qu'est ce que tu vas faire ici tu vois
je peux jouer peut-être comme 2
deux matchs deux oui notre part mais de
3h de jeu garde des jeux garmin est sur
le point qu'on ne sait jamais tu me
gardent un oeil sur pied un 5 tu menaces
toujours discrètement voilà c'est
puisque d'histoire donc j'ai un d'autant
que le fou maintenant mon silva pour en
revenir au match 4 9 6 ça a l'air bon
pied toujours quel vallée des saints qui
domine la vallée des seynes domine donc
ça a pas l'air d'avoir posé des
problèmes particuliers donc dames 6 t'as
joué quand même dame f3 au raid et là il
a très bien joué à abu dhabi c'est très
fort voilà cette réforme
je pense et meilleure défense meilleure
cote défense sans doute effectivement à
noter que surprise tension ya toujours
dame prend échec ouais j'ai commencé
vraiment paniqué et ce que je sentais
que ça m'échappe et partir de là
commence à pleuvoir de ton ouais parce
qu'avant je savais que j'étais bien et
là c'est je trouve ce n'est plus aussi
clair maintenant aussi clair mais ils
vont quand même bien seul
bref l objectif c'était d'aller au 40e
coup fondation tout peuple mais parce
qu'on est au 30e 1 500 d'élire le plus
beaucoup de temps donc 30 des trois
attaques cavalière toujours pareil il
vaut mieux faire un échec du fou avant
bastia il menace le coup qui me faisait
peur là c'était qu'elle est à trois
plutôt que l'échec
d'accord ce que je trouve ça fou est
plutôt bien on décide alors et il va
plus à travers du coup notre jeu sur une
option celle des lacs tour c'est 8 après
il ya un peu peur de ça bon d'accord
qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu faire ici va
peut-être que je peux jouer juste
puis on prend 1,6 peut-être qu'ils
entrent en insistant et donc oui peuvent
tour ses huit d'un emprunt alors sur
d'après je vais jouer flottera comme
j'ai chassé le cavalier seul pour ça que
j'ai fait mettra donc il va pas bien
c'est un peu trop à ces huit évidence
que peut-être juste protéger fait retour
des deux menaces matin oui
attention donc la tour d2 attention le
problème tour des deux os x et que tu
pourrais te faire clouer plus tard
maintenant talent fou au toit balade
face à l'aja plus du tout contrôle sur
ce qui se passe comment ça commence à
chauffer un goy la bomba
bon la salade des encore mais ça fait ça
fait peur en a pas beaucoup de temps et
l état tout rapidement à la fois être
défensive et offensive et battu joseph
l'autre on tourne le droit d'obliger 2
donc data continue le cavalier continue
ce qu avait quand même beaucoup plus
beau que celui-là même si bon il
corriere à ses fins de pénurie je pense
que là ça c'est quand même un peu les
bleus l'avantagé blanc quand un peuple
est beaucoup moins grand que tout à
l'heure
d'accord alors donc là issifou à 3 donc
un petit retournement on va dire moi je
sais pas s'ils mangent les maugeois
tourna key à trois je sais pas moins
émotionnelle génial on va dire c'était
fou rodez 1
on va bien et là tout est vite tombée
805 direct ou c'est à dire qu'en cas
maintenant il faut regarder si tu avais
pris et aux cavaliers sera sans doute
été une faute voilà parce qu'ils payent
à ces chacun des 6 check à la découverte
si je fais qu'avaient les v6 comme dans
leur si tu viens ici ça a l'air
sans doute au moins un nul pour lui
puisqu'il affichait qui check
donc il ya au moins le nul peut-être
sans doute mieux ouais à vérifier mais
sans doute mieux donc c'est dangereux
quand même voilà donc si l'on apprend
que tu ferais calais b 6190 là c'est
pire en fait donc donc là tu serais
obligé humaines de faire ça en fait mais
là je suis pas sûr que tu perdes
peut-être nul quand même échec
oui c'est dur de laisser jouer au jour
de deux variantes on n'a pas envie non
c'est sûr on n'a pas envie parce que là
on ce qu'on voudrait passer qu'adam
arriver là ça fait peur ça fait peur
mais ils en ont la nulle ouais ou pas
sûr qu'il est plus sain pas sûr mais bon
c'est quand même pas ça tu veux parce
que at on réussi gratuit en plus la
beauce et c'est que si je prends le cas
lui est prêt si je touche à rien il a
pas tant que ça ne me laisse donc ouais
j'aime l'info page de la feuille il ne
faut pas s'affoler donc tu as joué
tranquille comme g3 je n'étais pas
tranquille mais bon la mg3 tu sais tu
pas tranquille donc c'est pas facile
mais il n'y ait pas de menaces
peut-être je sais juste au coeur de
garder la position comme certains
qualifient ce qui menace quand même si
parce que tu vas tu vas sur quel et 6 kg
on prend puis on prend même si souvent
qu'on prend 1,6 d'ailleurs parce que le
plus on pourra la dame après ensuite
droit il s'est efforcé d'un échec
et non ça marche pas parce qu'il vit par
ans m il n'est pas oublier de prendre
plus sûres que les fc tir de missile et
le roi messi prend pas il peut pas se
prendre un cas les 17 norme et non l
intéresse peuvent faire tout et oui mais
attention la tour il pas défendue non
plus mais bon soit il faut aussi je veux
si je bouge le canadien aurait cette
fois vraiment je vous assure que ce soit
pour un truc qui gagne voilà je levais
slam national un faux pas le bouger
ah oui ah oui ça y est dans cette partie
ci position tu as aussi une menace qui
est pénible qu'on avait vaguement bus il
faut à cet âge ai pas pensé du tout
parce que falise et à défendre à la fois
la huitième qu'elle est au 6e tour des
800 salariés sera là voilà voilà après
il ya la tour qui peut venir en des huit
lits des deux fois 7 ici mais alors
c'est pas c'est là peut-être oui c'est
peut-être ici même pour lui de dames
chez 3 mais bon c'est pas facile à voir
mais ça veut pas dire que je sais pas du
tout si c'est bon pas on l'a vu en live
un sens c'est sympa on se sent parfois
cette attaque de la tour donc si la tour
verra le problème c'est qu'elle
s'éloigne de la défense dit si je peux
prendre dans ces cas là jeunesse le flou
avec la c4 et s'il prend de la tour bel
pareil il affaiblit la huitième et il
peut se passer des quasi mat
donc il faut faire grève quoi donc pas
du tout surtout qu'en prenant là tu
attaques le fou donc alors et s'il fait
pour bessette et bien il a affaibli la
huitième rang j'ai donc là on peut
envisager des bouquets sky et si c'est
chez alors après il peut toujours
couverte floch 8 auxerre
quand je fais tourner huit mois au frais
ouais il ya toujours fuite mais alors si
ici prendre comme ça voilà voilà voilà
voilà donc là il ya tour échec
et alors qu'est ce qu'il fait là
maintenant fuite voilà la foulée suite
c'est simple de l'erreur
qui peut encore faire ombrage certains
aussi un ouais ouais c'est donc voilà
tellement peu importe c'est possible et
c'est cet homme n'est pas facile à
calculer tout cas c'est un thème de
surcharge ce qui est le huitième plus il
faut qu'ils passent à venir merci c'est
moi qui ai trouvé voilà donc tout jeune
j'ai trouvé bon c'est vrai qu'il faut
calculer quoi ses partenaires afin de se
faire découper trop compromettants pour
arriver au 40e coup et alors là mur de
plus pour papier de panique donc
hp est sec apparemment mais bon
d'apprendre les 5,6 il a quand même
laissé ouvrir la colonne ici tu as comme
la dame âgée cette tension qui
contrôlent des huit là avec la tourbe
rang ceci dit la case hct la bon mais
c'est toujours au fond il a peut être
sonné mais c'est toujours moi qui ai
plutôt lui qui doit faire attention
celui qui doit faire attention et
notamment parce que lui il a beau avoir
fait des échecs
y a rien fait et y arrive hélas pas tant
que tant qu'on bouge pas y'a rien là
rouages suite tout jeune en ass mat jeu
c'est simple ça mange pas de pain comme
dit l'autre à toi de jouer
oui et puis moment ils l'ont peut-être
que je sais pas s'il a un problème parce
que ben c'est pas facile de défendre ça
c'est pas facile parce que du coup son
la dame je peux prendre le cavalier quoi
alors à noter que le toujours le
problème c'est que cibula tour en
défense par exemple on peut envisager
peut-être même sur sûrement mais quand
on perd une pièce répondait c'est la
surcharge aussi de la tour là cette
défense indirects qui laisse la pression
est en fait peut s'avérer un problème en
plus on est rassurés d'avoir des armes
ici parce que la case de ouais on
empêche un échec
donc là un problème qu'est ce qu'on fait
là si on bouge la tour c'est ça qui pose
problème
ils auraient pu revenir avec le fou
peut-être et non un nom pareil père
lecavalier
parce que surprendre mais on s'éloigne
et puis quand même soit comme lecavalier
est super fort je peux aller me cacher
peut-être sur la colonne des plus tu
peux te cacher sur la colonne des
mesures de ce que ceux qui avaient
tellement paraît tout à fait ça colle
mais très bien donc le seul autre coup
bas c'est finalement c'est ce qu'il a
fait mais il n'a pas le choix et la
jolie tranquille sang froid
regardez bien magnifique boum et tout
simplement tranquille jean-françois
puisque après plus en prend 1,6 seller
regardes et tu comprends et oui parce
que maintenant qui a pu les dames c'est
plus du tout aussi dangereux que tout à
l'heure et surtout vous allez voir
regardez après puis on prend ces quatre
bien sûr je joue pas au rabé deux parce
que les noirs en l'annulant je pense
qu'ils sont contents parce que tellement
ils ont fait pas non plus fous b6 ont
fait pas non plus l'erreur fou b6 caf ou
c5 parce que là des noirs jour est fou
c'est 5 qui récupère le matos et la
finale est nul
sans doute mais ils font pour la jouer
mais c'est nul bon mais ce n'est pas
l'idée parce qu'après pions prend ses
quatre regard des très jolies cavaliers
b6 et là je pense qu'il n'a pas le temps
de profiter du cloud est normalement
alors là il a par exemple ou des six
pouces est seul mais je vois pas quel
taux alors voilà elle avec le fou
sauvage bougeront voilà le roi samba et
le cavalier pourra sortir alors l'autre
il décide de jouer si c'était ça me
faisait très peur ça devrait pas trop
mais peut-être que j'ai le temps d'aller
manger ce que je peux je tour g 3g
peut-être le temps d'aller manger voilà
voilà ici le la solution est alors faite
aux joueurs d'abord l'histoire prendre
la colonne autour des 3 après alors
c'est trop subi menaces parce que c'est
là c'est quand même désagréables as
commencé dans la boîte mais
le roi peut pas sortir mais s'il vient
en il ya foule et deux chiens là et
après on revient c'est quand même
désagréables enfin ça doit les ont
touché trois îles des tours j'ai trois
c'est d'attaquer ça si ça saute c'est
terminé parce qu'après la tournée de
même venir enlever trois ans et ses
rennes donc la laci fait tour des huit
jeux proposent les change de tous les
torts des huit pour finir mattia pas de
maths parce qu'on fait autour des droits
la menace est ça donc le seul coup qui
tient un peu c'est fou des cadres parce
que si je fous fous fous b2b d'être je
vais peut-être faire a4 ou a3 pour me
libérer me permettra de quinze ans
surtout b2 il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas deux mais même si au fond
et à d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de
découverte ou pénibles mais je vais
quand même faire un caprice forme d'une
petite case peut-être bref support mais
a passé un bac à glace il faut 20 ans
bécade là je fais roi c'est en avant à
chaque fois là bas si je me cachais par
la cia et s'il fait froid b2c sur les
deux bons lors du coup le fou rire mais
c'est pas vraiment le cas valait donc
j'ai peut-être le temps ge peut-être
faire à quatre vivent maintenant à 4 à 4
suffi et le rêve aller en b3 voilà cela
je pense que je m'en sors oui là c'est
bon de will c'est fini tu as ta pièce de
plus se terminer donc ici cavaliers b6
ben c'est un très joli coup alors une
tente le dernier truc c'est fou des
quatre pour l'avenir en face elle offre
une fois ce mois là mais là c'est le
moment pour moi c'est un brassin il ya
plus sur flash et consorts le roi c'est
fini du monde le roi sort on garde la
pièce de plus donc jolie combinaison
prévue à la fin il n'a pas essayé de
mater au final il a il avait que les
changes des dames transposer d'un final
gagnant pour gagner une pièce faut
garder son sang froid en fait c'est ça
le truc donc la foule ces trois bons
lycées de mardin mini pression ici mais
s'est terminée après car il prend ses 4
on va voir que bon il a essayé encore un
peu tomber tours baker
on est retourné jouer tour b 4 qu'est
née de notre cahier des deux jolis coups
et fait contrôler la casserole avec
d'autres stéphane c'est le moment que
j'ai choisi pour me lever j'ai fait une
chute juste devant devant l'échiquier
quasiment tous ceux qui étaient dans la
salle
voilà ça se rappelleront en ce moment
parce que tu étais nerveux rouge
j'imagine parce que tu sentais que tu as
donné la victoire alors j'ai comme un
fou bah oui oui j'ai de quoi toi 4 parce
que c'est pas qu'une victoire contre un
joueur c'est aussi une victoire de plus
dans un national superbe donc tour à 4
et la très jolie soit 4 alors à noter
quand même que il abandonne ici
sebastian webber mais l'abandon après
jean presque un quart d'heure de
réflexion quand même
il a essayé encore de trouver les
ressources
mais là y'a rien parce qu'en fait la
menace des blanches et très forte c'est
de jouer un fief si celle-ci imaginons
que les noirs prennent en a deux voilà
faut laisser sécher mes fils échec c'est
tout j'essaie tout les sept projets de
suite et maintenant regarder up échec à
la découverte et le fou a sauté terminé
tu as fait de pied de quelque chose de
plus rideau un saint soufi est en fait
le seul solution pour garder les pieds
si je veux sauf des quatre voies la voie
pourquoi aussi possible l'intérêt c'est
qu'on garde un mini attaque sur sur la
sas a immobilisé un peu cavalier mais ça
fait rien ça suffira largement pour les
blancs en fait à la fin il peut on peut
quand même bouger le cavalier peut
jamais prendre 4 parce que justement
elle est toujours autour des sept g7
donc superbe victoire super à un moment
clé il faut tenir en formant les nerfs
quand même septièmement du national ça
te fait donc
quatre ans et demi mais quel point tu à
égalité donc avec yannick gozzoli
mathieu cornette qu'on fait nul rapide
enfin semi rapides aujourd'hui on va
dire pas rapide mais seulement keane et
puis juste derrière vous vous avez donc
très signer et bauer qui ont fait match
nul
donc en fait c'est toi le vainqueur de
la halle de la journée puisque tu es le
seul du groupe de tête à avoir remporté
un doigt est ce qui permet de compenser
finalement tu as pertes d'hier et bt la
té disponibles pour aller remplir en
podium pourquoi pas irréel est si réelle
mais c'est possible
donc voilà donc superbe superbe tournoi
de jean-françois joli conte est super
heureux et je suis super heureux de
l'avoir reçu deux fois merci f1 duo
diagonale tv est-ce que je peux profiter
de la vidéo pour faire un petit coucou à
mes élèves dernier au salon il faut il
faut un seul comme je vois pas ce que
peut-être pas souvent voilà merci
stéphane voilà donc dans leur intérieur
nous voterons aussi bien sûr voilà et
qui sont combien de temps à combien il
est facile
c'est difficile à compter avec tous ceux
des écoles je sais pouvoir avec les
écoles on est à plusieurs centaines
d'élèves qui découvre les échecs ou
qu'ils approfondissent les échecs pour
monter d'écran en jeu d'échecs
approfondir voilà le jeu d'échecs qui
est magnifique qui me permet de vivre de
belles aventures comme celle de jean
françois joly cette année dans le
national 2016 merci jean françois
mercier stéphane merci nous avoir suivi
sur des gones ltv pour cette septième
ronde à juin 2016 cette magnifique
victoire de jean françois joly la
sensation on peut le dire ça restera ça
restera la sensation de cette agence est
quoi qu'il arrive dans les dernières
dernière ronde il aura fait un
magnifique tournoi
merci de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
sur tes bonal tv